[Music]
this week we've got wooly comeback
trash library and camel contest I heard
about the camel contest they've got a
camel toe contest like who's got the
bigger camel toe it's way more I do I
was just thinking of actual like camels
y'all brought first story
scientists have said that they're just
two years away from bringing the woolly
mammoths back from extreme please I want
to see a woolly mammoth so bad they've
been talking about this [ __ ] for [ __ ]
years dude there's some Jurassic Park
ass [ __ ] what if this [ __ ] comes
how what's the size difference between a
woolly mammoth on a regular it's like
three times the size
okay what if they bring this
[ __ ] back in this bull runs out
of the zoo and starts killing people
then that would be an amazing JK new
story they wouldn't a strip he kind of
looks like snuffleupagus that's exactly
what's his name an ice age Ray Romano
yeah yes they're saying that they have
been using gene editing to try to bring
back the woolly mammoths they've been
successful in switching 45 sections of
DNA with elephants Wow
woolly mammoths in them elephants like a
hybrid type of creature here that
they're trying to create and they'll be
having they'll be growing this creature
in an artificial womb they were
considering having an elephant be the
surrogate but since elephants right now
they're their species is under threats
they don't want it oh yeah that makes
sense I wonder what they taste like
yeah I mean you know what that used to
be a pretty big source of meat for human
you know they say LF and me is [ __ ]
bomb really yeah allows it's like the
best meat in the world no it's it's been
rumored by people that enjoy like a wild
game like caribou elk elephant stuff
like that
they say elephant meat is actually very
very delicious yeah I'm trying to eat it
animal it looks like ball skin dude
that's just like you
I hear it's good oh my god Hicks kin
kind of looks like ball sack but it like
to stretch that a little bit no have you
seen elephants get that she looks
straight out like ball skin two guys
spend comparing animals to Bulls
elephant just looks like ashy elbows
yeah yeah the whole body is ashy elbow
like a really dry cold scrotum oh yeah
I wonder imagine if it was like it
became a real thing and it was as
friendly as a real elephant and just
wants to cuddle with those tusks i but I
don't think so yeah I think it's a
violent creature they're supposed to be
very docile yeah they're first from what
I've read I think docile
in comparison to the animals like the
saber-tooth Tiger probably but I think
in terms of animals these days I think
those guys are probably pretty
aggressive I think from what I've read
to like the one they're gonna bring
because of the gene splicing it's not
gonna be the same size a little
amendment it's gonna be like half the
size so it's still gonna be big it's
supposed to be bigger than an elephant
but it's not gonna be as big as a woolly
I don't know it's a Kevin Hart version
of a woolly mammoth I want the real one
times the size of an actual elephant the
actual size of arm I think they put a
picture if you look it up you can see a
picture comparison it's like
substantially larger um why did they go
extinct again did cavemen eat them all I
think Katie Ann killed them I thought
they froze today yeah I thought cavemen
killed them force them off cliffs humans
survived the Ice Age that's all these to
hunt them they would get Spears and and
surround them on and and push them off
to quit outsmarted them yeah
humans are very smart so here's it it's
a dangerous tool if they're hungry and
smart this is not big a family member
holy moly oh my god this looks like the
baby of this I would love to see that
guy in real life can you imagine riding
one no no riding elephants they're not
even gonna know you're on yeah sure
launch your ass off you're dead I want
them to carry me in their tusks I also
want them to bring back the Tasmanian
Devil yeah the Tasmanian not that has
made devil the Tasmanian Tiger whatever
the little one saber-toothed tiger no it
was the Tasmanian Mastodon you know it
was didn't go extinct too long ago so
there's that the dodo bird I want that
[ __ ] back that [ __ ] was done though but
it was like the easiest like hunting
bird out there so that's why I went
extinct is no such an easy source of
food if the dodo could exist I mean if
the sloth can exist in the dodo can also
come back yeah they just ate them all to
death well who can kill themselves oh
yeah because they fall off let's grab
their own arms as a parent yeah there's
that's the funniest thing I've ever any
think it's a branch like oh [ __ ] swim
they swim
yeah and he was just like wow this is
amazing then one of the slots were
serving in their poisonous [ __ ] wow it's
pretty [ __ ] cool swimming they're
just floating that's really slow at a
pretty normal I met I met a sloth when I
was when I'll still go game saying there
was a store in downtown LA that's sold
bikinis yeah and then this the lady that
sewed the bikinis she was like an animal
saving whatever like she saves wild
animals and so I go into her story she
always has [ __ ] rabbits and birds
running around she's like you want seen
a sloth I'm like what she was a sloth
I'm like okay she brings up with this
giant Rubbermaid a boxing the rubber
thing and lifts off the lid there was
just a slice chilling inside with the
blanket I'm cute and I stuck my hand
down he went
later he like grabbed my hand brings it
back just smells it awesome Wow
you have done if she says want to see my
sloth you go yeah she shows you her
vagina so [ __ ] hairy ass vagina [ __ ]
why'd she have the slaw in a Tupperware
because the legs are the slaw but I
would laugh pretty hard yeah she's had
all these crazy animal should like
fennec foxes and [ __ ] O's dope always
was an adventure no when I first read
this I was like why would they want to
bring wooly mammoths back like what's
the point of that where anything so much
effort into this but there's a reason
and they're saying that by reintroducing
woolly mammoths to frozen parts of the
planet it will help reduce the melting
ice because with their tusks they are
able to punch through the snow and then
allow it to cold air to come in and keep
it from melting somehow what I think
they should do is bring back all the
big-ass [ __ ] animals so they could
wipe us all out and have a and have a
no-rules day and then just let mother
nature have one quick reset day and see
what happens it's Mother Nature purge
yup if buildings get knocked down people
die whatever let it be and then we'll
start back up the next day I will say
this bark Lanka president that's a good
idea
yep alright right next story there are
these garbage collectors in Turkey
that's saved all the books that they
found in the trash and they actually
opened up a library who throws away but
a lot of people the mom throws away your
mum's it teacher isn't she uh mommy
she's retired but so she just gave up on
education she says so right now this
might even sound a little dark but she
just sees it like I'm at the end of my
like years like why am I gonna hold onto
shits if someone wants to take it she
they'll take it but then she's like I
read a book but what am I gonna do with
it like it's just gonna sit there like
I'm just gonna toss it but you could
literally put in a bag donate to a
library yeah and they'll take it off
don't I mean yeah voices of reason but
that's I'm not my mom I don't know there
was
every time I move a charge up her and
excuse me every time I look over her lip
liner gets darker at the East End lay is
strong in this one
that's how easily girls get energy
they'll keep moving generates energy
it's like a watch they fight they move
so much so the earrings can charge up
that's good head movement yes here's the
library did they just have a random
visitor bill that's all library that
looks like a [ __ ] crack motel oh no
it's just that this building just so
happens to be like the crack motel for
them at library they're saying initially
when they started this mini library was
just for the garbage collectors and for
their family okay well actually they a
lot of people heard about this library
started donating more books now they
have over 6,000 book holy [ __ ] now it's
open for the public everyone just goes I
will say this though recently I walked
into the what do you call that store
borders I haven't been in upwards in
years yeah it's the ORS at Barnes and
Barnes & Noble been to either in years
there's the one in Glendale I don't know
yeah one of the B pitches for books
right so I just walked in that place man
I like books man may not read them but I
like being around them and I like
opening up as if I'm going to learn
something but that's that's if it's like
educational for a hobby that I want you
know it sounds like I'm not gonna read
it for entertainment it's gonna be for a
specific purpose so you don't read
novels no I stopped reading that type of
[ __ ] so it's like script writing books
or whatever but or like photography
books or it'll be like something kind of
subject that I like but if it's for
entertainment I don't do that [ __ ]
anymore
I love the concept of a book yes that
it's between pages there's lots of
information I just don't like that you
have to read it I wish I could just
invite looks even that's too long
exactly Wow I know a lot like that but
going in Pingo colorful store feels
pretty damn dope though I don't know I
like it a lot man I like the fact that
is I could see what I might
I was going there and I got mm-hmm
mm-hmm mmm going Amazon goodbye for a
third of the price expensive do know
that shit's like some $15 for a book you
could buy a used boat for two dollars
like use books though I want my ship why
i want my ship freshest [ __ ] i want it
where the other Kaizen already
highlighted behind me all new books
right would open I want it to [ __ ]
crack like my elbows yeah like book
chemicals yeah cuz I got used books
because it was cheaper but people
already pre highlighted my face yeah I
don't got to do any more if you guys
like my books I probably highlighted the
entire thing because I was that's the
[ __ ] that pissed me off like I would
read this [ __ ] right I'm like why are
you highlighting this there's no
information in that the word oh you mean
a minute and they just have this
squiggly and they can't even draw a
straight line it's like [ __ ] squiggly
it's like the preamble to everything and
then they're like highlighting [ __ ] it's
like what is this when I first started
learning how to highlight I use to
highlight everything so I thought
everything was important well that's
that's the moon-god know that yeah I
know that I just highlight the whole
page you know my mom's are you're not
doing it right
I probably already your voice yeah and
the page numbers I hand evil folder
pages to bookmark it bothers me better
than I know I like bookmarks I hated him
addition to so they would highlight the
thing right and their note for the
highlight is the exact it would piss me
off it'll be like animals dah dah dah
dah so cool this is important and they
put a little line next to it and they
just rewrite hated that [ __ ] you can
highlight on your Kindle you have a
Kindle I've been thinking of buying one
all the books no no it's on your phone
you just download the Kindle app and you
could read book their own books thing
too yeah but I mean you don't really
need it if you just use your phone
people like Kindles because it lasts
long
the under the battery is [ __ ] lasts
forever on top of that too it has like a
certain yeah it doesn't [ __ ] up with
your eyes the only people I know that
those are white people think Christian
and then they're like honey did you
bring the candle yes I did mom all right
disappointed in she's imagined I can't
bring his kingdom while eating cottage
cheese people eat cottage cheese all
right for our last story so about a
dozen camels were banned from a beauty
contest after the judges found out that
their owners were using Botox to enhance
their futures there's a camel beauty
contest you bye dude it's a [ __ ]
Instagram camel in Saudi Arabia oh [ __ ]
I just imagine that cameras like
[Music]
apparently they use it that's a flash as
though yes people yes
and they smell like [ __ ] you smelled one
you've never been at the zoo I never
what I don't remember them smelling oh
they smell really bad dude when I was
with that when we were with the prince
in Abu Dhabi Oh your life is amazing I
know but just that statement I don't
know ever be able to make that statement
well you know the kinkajou Molly so when
you were with the prince if you remember
how I told you like he has like that
whole room full of cars he also had a
camel in the corner of stuff camel
apparently it was like their prized
camel that died because like a spider
bit it Oh like taxidermy animals spider
I felt like he was stuck like not
literally stuff like me you've never
seen a camel spider do they bite spot
camel there's there's been one so
they're known as camel spiders
apparently that's not their actual name
oh dude look like crabs no yeah they'll
sleep under the belly of a [ __ ] camel
like god they're huge they're like this
[ __ ] big oh my god absolutely
disgusting they're not them venomous but
they will [ __ ] sorry huh they're
furry is figure out
girl what are they eat like rats and
stuff they eat anything do we eat them
which one is it there's so many this one
there's a big-ass one right here look at
this [ __ ] do you think they'll be
delicious like crab this is too attached
my friends in Afghanistan said they saw
those and they stepped on it in a crunch
like a lousy [ __ ] jumping weather
these two right here oh my god that's
that's an ant that's a spider ant it
looks like a bigger eating each other
fighting you like the size it like both
of them is the size of this dude's like
[ __ ] she's so one of them's
emphasized your thigh imagine I should
come in at you like some sci-fi [ __ ] so
so the camel got bit by a spider and it
died yeah it was like their prized
racing camel or some [ __ ] they're like
worth like [ __ ] millions like tens of
millions of dollars up late is it cuz
the file name is fake camel spider is it
that's real I've seen look up real camel
spider then yeah I don't know there's so
many dude let me see it no okay yeah so
they got they got busted for being fakes
and fulminate so apparently they use
Botox for the lips nose upper lips lower
lips which I don't know why it's a la
camel number Botox just freezes your
muscles shouldn't they put like doesn't
it fill it out though isn't it like a
fuller maybe they apparently the way it
works with the camels it does make their
head look bigger somehow oh that's
[ __ ] up and then apparently they also
found a veterinarian
they caught him performing cosmetic
surgery on camels to make their ears
look smaller and then he was only giving
Botox so small years make a camel
prettier I don't know apparently they
judge them on a lot of things it's a
camel beauty contest yeah and then like
the prize is 31.8 million I would cheat
- what does I get it yeah it's [ __ ] up
but I get it this country money and
boredom yeah there's this camel festival
in Saudi Arabia where I want to go a
whole bunch of different you know
competitions like beauty contests they
also like ride the camels and they're
like about 30,000 camels in this event
so yeah the prize money is huge but
again we're 3,000 cash
not 31 million dollars that like how
much do you need for everyone's entry
fee to like crowdsource 31 million
dollars that's a lot of [ __ ] money
that I mean all the sponsors everyone
that's contesting everyone has to bring
that's like a World Series of Poker and
[ __ ] that's just a few billionaires I
just do it yeah probably
it's money and board it man they're just
looking for [ __ ] 31 million I get my
camel breast implants humping plans
there's like some camels that got two
humps and some camels that have one huh
its male and female that's pretty
[ __ ] good you got me I was like well
fascinating camels last long in a desert
and horses die you know why I don't know
is it the water yeah they keep it in
their hump and this is for real they're
meant to be desert and yeah cuz they
don't need to drink that much water
because they can store it in the they
store fat in their home have you guys
seen the inside of a camels mouth
that shit's [ __ ] horrifying it took
me look that should have
oh boy camels mouth camels I've never
had that angle before it smelled one I
feel like I wrote a camel drops thing
what is it what is it well that's weird
right that's what I'm saying it really
for real yeah that's the camels mouth
okay look at that
that's it Christmas it's loading like
the 90s let me see if I shouldn't which
I mean here you know what in the world
what am I looking at I don't get it the
mouth to see the teeth it's all
what's so weird about what are all the
squishy things on the side it looks like
a cat's tongue it's like wet fur from my
angle it's good it looks like crab gills
or something yeah I can see why it's
gross
that's gross I can't look at her sure
what is it supposed to do squishing your
finger in there maybe it helps them when
they're eating their desert grass yeah
maybe that's where they store it cuz I
remember reading as a kid that they
would store food on their cheeks how
cute
I like when squirrels do that [ __ ]
[Music]